LOGAN ROY: Everything I've done
in my life,
I've done for my children.
I know I've made mistakes,
but I've always tried
to do the best by them
because...
I love them.
THERAPIST: Have you thought
about the possibility
that your children
are actually scared of you?
Oh, fuck off!
I want a broadcast network.
I wanna see
what other news operations
we can sweep up.
-Local TV?
-ROMAN ROY: Dad,
nobody watches TV.
Why shouldn't we do
all the news?
Um, well, Kim Jong Pop,
because that's not
how things work in this country.
KENDALL ROY: We have
a major problem.
He's erratic,
he's making bad decisions.
If he's not careful,
he's going to
destroy the company.
Anyway, you gonna
do something'?
I think I'm the best option.
Oh right,
'cause you like playing boss?
KENDALL: This is my vision.
-I take over, you two under me.
-Under you?
-Can we think about it?
-KENDALL: Yeah, of course.
Yeah, I've thought about it.
Fuck you.
CONNOR ROY: This family
is broken
and that has consequences.
Take out the old man,
in with the new guard.
-LOGAN: Where you been?
-SIOBHAN ROY: I was meeting
-about a prospective job.
-With your father's enemy?
Disagreeing with dad
is not treason.
Do you want this enough
to go to war with your family?
It's rebellion!
Sabotage!
Deliberate attempt
to undermine my whole business.
That's the death pit,
take a look.
GREG: I feel like
I might not like it
in the death pit.
Stock's gone below 130.
We could death-spiral here.
Who's in charge right now?
It's my company,
you are a fucking nobody.